Sophisticated analysis of genomic DNA can provide insight
into individual's ancestry. But most nuclear DNA undergoes
a recombination over successive generations. And therefore patterns
of ancestry decay more quickly in these regions.
To look back into our deeper past, we
need to look at DNA sequence information that's
directly inherited and not involved in meiotic recombination.
In this diagram here of all the human
chromosomes, I want you to tell me which two chromosomes do not
experience significant recombination over many generations.
There's a checkbox associated with each chromosome
1 through 22, the X to Y and mitochondrial chromosome. I want
you to pick the two that
don't experience significant recombination over many generations.